tunisia's president has announced that
he now has the power to dismiss judges
and has removed their right to strike
kaya syed's decree follows the
dissolution of the supreme judiciary
committee one of the last institutions
independent of the presidency it's the
latest contentious move by saeed since
he sacked tunisia's government and froze
parliament last july
elitia volkman joins us now on the phone
from tunis so alexia just explain to us
exactly what is happening and what it
means so there's a new temporary
judicial council
yes the new decree has created this new
temporary judicial council as uh last
sunday he issued a decree that dissolved
the old supreme judicial council which
was the the watchdog over the justice
system and the judiciary
but there's been a long bitter wrangle
between the president and the supreme
judicial council since september when he
declared he was ruling solely by decree
so he gathered the three powers of state
executive legislative and judicial in
his hands but the judges have have
pushed back against this because they
say they're independent and they demand
autonomy
uh on the the other side there has been
a lot of criticism of the judiciary and
uh of corruption in the judiciary so
there has been some popular support for
kai side
but there's uh there's also been a
backlash from like g7 states from the un
you know decrying what he's done uh
because there's a big difference between
you know a strong reform of an
organization that has issues of
corruption and completely abolishing it
so what we've seen since then is that
judges have been on strike the
the supreme judicial council has
actually taken the ministry of interior
to court demanding the keys to their
headquarters back but we're still
waiting on the judgment for this
and there's been a strong pushback
against donor states the eu as and now
in discussion about whether or not
they're going to continue to support the
tunisian state financially and that's
looking very fragile so rather than the
appeasing process that side seemed to
take early in the week by offering this
temporary judicial council
and his foreign affairs minister trying
to appease g7 states it seems that he's
gone back to his much more sort of
authoritarian sort of strongman
type of resolutions
and today there will be a march
demanding the reopening of the superior
judicial council so
there's still you know as they say in
football all to play for
that was my next question with this
planned protest i mean how might this
impact things are people allowed to
together under covered rules i mean
might this this latest move fire up the
protesters
yeah this um i mean this will certainly
you know put fire in the protesters
bellies for sure
it's a complex situation because
undercoverd rules uh you know big
gatherings and protests are still banned
i was speaking with the you know the
executive committee of citizens against
the coup who organizing this protest and
they said that they actually had come to
some kind of agreement with the police
about how the demonstration was going to
play out because there's certainly a lot
of discontent within the police force
because they've been purges and they
feel you know in a very fragile position
they're very aware that tunisia is
losing its status on the
international stage and they're very
concerned about this because the armed
forces and the security forces have
benefited greatly from the donor states
in terms of reform improvements
equipment so they're very very worried
themselves so
this does change things you know kai
side may replace you know the the forces
who normally um you know guard and
secure marches we at the moment we don't
know uh before we were expecting a
relatively peaceful demonstration that
would be allowed to go to the superior
judicial council headquarters
um
within you know within the constraints
of you know law and order governed by
the police
but now everything's changed so we'll
have to watch and wait and see how the
day plays out
that we will all right for now thank you
for that alexia walkman there live from
tunis